foreign
Valerie what's up Valerie
hi can you hear me okay oh my gosh that
sounds amazing how are you
oh I'm good thank you thank you for
taking my call of course of course so
what in the world's up
uh well I guess my question is
um How do I
forgive myself
for allowing someone to mistreat me how
do I move forward
wow that's heavy tell me more about it
um I was in a in a relationship with
this person for almost two years
and um towards I guess the last uh maybe
eight months
um things got really bad he never
physically touched me but it was more of
like the verbal views and financially I
was dependent on him
for oh for the last six months and he
was always
like when we get into an argument and um
he would be like well I'm gonna take the
money out of the account and I would I
wouldn't have access to it
or he one time
got we got into an argument and my
family was in town and
he was drinking and he knew I was going
to need my car
and he ended up taking my car and
driving to a bar and I'm like trying to
reach him why did you take my car and
his answer was to make you feel
uncomfortable
hmm
do you all have kids do you all have
kids together
I
to give a little bit more background I
cheated on him in the beginning of the
relationship and I got pregnant
and we both knew that we weren't sure
whether it was going to be his or not
and he decided that we were going to
continue and work on the relationship
but then when we took the test and it
was in his his reaction towards me and
the baby
completely changed sure
sure
all right um
I wanna I wanna uh change directions a
bit is that cool that's fine
sometimes in a situation like the one
you're in
or a situation where we
fall in love with somebody we trust
somebody we take a job with somebody
and then they don't just not treat us
well but they hurt us
sometimes it's easier
to blame ourselves because we feel like
we could actually fix that
it's harder to live in a world
where somebody says I love you
and then strands you in the middle of
nowhere while you're pregnant
or somebody takes all the money out of
your account and says you have to go
through me
that world is terrifying because those
are supposed to be the the people that
ride or die with you right those are
supposed to be the people that love you
and so self-blame is often the easiest
place to go
foreign
but it's not right
and so what I would tell you is I don't
know that Valerie needs to beat up
Valerie Valerie doesn't need to forgive
Valerie because Valerie didn't do
anything wrong Valerie learned some new
information
some new lessons
right what Valerie has to do is learn to
live in a world where
you can be completely vulnerable in
somebody that you love is going to hurt
you
and then the question is who is going to
Valerie who who is Valerie going to be
on the back end of that
right that's a scary world right
it is
it's a scary world I'm sorry that he
treated you that way you didn't deserve
them
since I emailed you guys thanks
obviously changed and I've I moved out
and my family has my back and
is just I feel
like I failed
yeah
what did what did you fail Valerie
foreign
I don't know I guess I wanted that
perfect family and yeah you what you
feel is grief
because you had a picture in your head
of how things were going to turn out and
then it didn't happen that way
and you have that that double-edged
sword right you would probably do
anything to take back cheating on this
guy
and getting pregnant and you get the
greatest gift in the whole world which
is a new baby right I I do and it's both
end
that's right it's both in and you
probably would um look back and think
well if I hadn't done this and hadn't
said this and hadn't exploded on him in
this one night and I I I contributed to
that's fine
but I'm gonna tell you nobody
with an ounce
of
I'll just be very specific to men nobody
with an ounce of masculinity in their
body nobody with an ounce of dignity or
respect in their body
strands their girlfriend or their wife
ever
that's cowardly childish behavior
no man with any sort of masculinity any
sort of strength or dignity or
responsibility
takes all the money out of the account
and says you got to go through me as
though you're some kind of Overlord or
her dad
that's a cowardly childish behavior so
you are trying to look you're trying to
to
lean up against
a nine-year-old in an adult body and
wonder what you did wrong nothing
just a nine-year-old an adult body
his answer was always like well you did
this to me and it would always come
that's because he's a childish coward
he's a childish coward
my wife can't make me do anything
and I love her to the Moon and back
yeah
I choose my responses I choose my
actions I choose my thoughts I choose my
behaviors I choose I make choices
and she can frustrate me she can make me
sad she can break my heart she can make
me mad and then I choose what happens
next
and how dare any grown man
look at his friends his boss his wife
his kids and say you made me do bullcrap
he chose that
what you have to do is in a weird way
that's not even a weird way can I tell
you what I would recommend if you were
my sister or just a buddy of mine I
would recommend you hold some sort of
miniature vigil some sort of miniature
funeral for the picture you had in your
head of the perfect family
because you knew this baby was was not
his
and yet he said I'm in I'm in
he gave you an opportunity to Exhale and
to Dream a Little Bit
and if you're like most parents you
already have pictures of what your kid
coming home from college with some
knuckleheaded boy or some knuckleheaded
girl is going to look like and trying to
have Thanksgiving you already have those
pictures in your head and boom now
they're going to be different you have
to grieve that
I wanted this to happen and it's not
going to happen like this
it doesn't mean you're not going to have
joy doesn't mean you're not going to
have great relationships you're going to
fall in love again all those things are
still on the table and I would even go
as far as to say I think they're gonna
happen
that you have to grieve I thought this
one was going to happen and it's not
all right
do you have lessons to learn from this
on how you responded to things
I
definitely I mean for
phenos
right cool
for that same reason I allowed myself
for him to do all those things you know
like I felt like I was looking for that
forgiveness
and he ran right over you
I knew I deserved better I just
stay there so so yeah but but again
I mean I I'm
I can read the data
and it's terrifying for a mom with a
young child to consider the possibility
that I'm going to be a single mom
unable to provide for us or it's going
to be a drastic shift in how me and my
baby live
and I can Shield my baby from the hell
that I live in in exchange for a roof
and that women have been making that
choice for centuries
you're not crazy and you're not broken
you're trying to stay safe and the
courage you showed leaving this madness
is incredible
and did you do dumb stuff yes are we
gonna do it again no because from this
point forward Valerie is a woman who
never ever cheats again Valerie is a
woman who never disrespects herself
somebody else's husband or her own
person that she's in a relationship with
that's it
period done
so let's set that brick down and quit
carrying it around everywhere
and by the way
this is for everybody listening and you
if
somebody cheats on you somebody hurts
you somebody breaks your heart
and you go through a period of being
upset and angry and grief all the normal
things
and then you have a moment where you sit
with them and you say hey I'm all in
we're gonna get through this we're gonna
work through this I'm all in
from that point forward you have to
um you can't hold this crap over each
other anymore you gotta move on
you can't grovel for the rest of your
life you'll have to regain rebuild
something new and then you have to
commit to being vulnerable again both of
you
and that didn't happen here
no
so let's do two things first thing is I
want you to
get a couple of your family members who
ride or die a couple of friends and I
want you all to hold a small little
ceremony for what was going to be it's
not
let's call it just a small little
funeral of the dream of the perfect
little family
I think you're gonna have a perfect
little family moving forward but just
gonna look different than the one you
had in mind
let's have a small funeral for it and
then I want you to write Valerie a
letter
you
I want you to write what you learned in
this situation
the things that you wish you could do
over
I want you to to let Valerie know that
you love her
and here's who we're going to be moving
forward
then the goal is going to be to create a
life where you can live into that
where you're going to exercise where
you're going to work who you're going to
surround yourself with what you will and
will not tolerate in a romantic
relationship you get to pick all those
things
you get to choose that path forward
I'm proud of you for for making the move
stay on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
it's my last book and um
just gives you a path from
everything's in Ash and where do I go
from here
thank you so much for the call Valerie